and Joey Jones is on the phone with us
hi Joey hey guys how's it going uh let's
get your take we'll give you the
floor yeah listen if this were about the
turn it would have happened a couple of
months ago at least at least 150 some
odd strikes against the United States
ago uh this is about pacifying Americans
who are literally sitting here going
really we're going to let someone hit us
200 times and kill three of us now and
uh and injur dozens of us and uh and and
we're just going to say that you don't
that's our best policy here um you know
I hate to believe that presidential
politics has anything to do with keeping
Americans safe and I heard the judge
talk about that earlier on the show that
uh that that doing anything now may
potentially affect oil prices and then
escalate into a worse economic situation
at home well why is that what policies
led to that the truth is Jordan's
watching Saudi Arabia is watching Israel
for a matter of fact is watching and I
don't know that any of those countries
that we want to be an ally that we want
to be on our side if something were to
break out are being inspired by the
United States right now but what is
happening is that a lot of Americans are
sitting here going I don't think my
soner daughter needs to serve in this
military and I'm I'm for whatever
changes our perspective on our
government's ability to keep us safe
regardless of who the president is
that's not even a a hit against
President Biden as much as it is an
observation of where we are as a country
three Georgians were just welcome home
in casket and I can imagine their
families are sitting there going yeah
retribution they're probably sitting
there going I hope whatever happens
today and tomorrow on the next day stops
the next three families from mourning
three more Americans that were somewhere
we didn't most Americans didn't even
know they were doing something that most
Americans aren't aware that they're
doing good point judge Joey you know one
of the things that General Kellogg said
a few minutes ago he said Iran does not
want to go to war with the United States
and yet we all know that we can spend
all kinds of efforts going after the
proxies but but Iran is in charge and
the Iran trying to deny the connection
is absurd they Supply they train and
they pay them why is why is Iran pushing
us if they're afraid to go to war with
us do they have are they close to a
nuclear
weapon this is what I believe I believe
Iran got what they wanted already I mean
IM immediately after three Americans
were killed there's a dispute between
the United States and Jordan as to where
this happened because they don't want
this mess on their doorstep uh look at
what's happening in Israel look I mean
look at the fact that America is having
to excuse itself or answer for every
single thing it does in the Middle East
right now among its own people with a
presidential election coming up I think
for Iran that's enough they don't need
to go to war with us to show their
neighbors that we may not be as strong
as we say we are that we may not have as
strong of a voice within our country as
we say we do and I think that's the goal
for them is is the doubt among countries
that might align with the us or Israel
moving forward and I think that is where
they're winning right now I don't want
to go to war with Iran I'm not Lindsey
Graham listen I I spent eight years
fighting two Wars over there and I know
less about it today than I did when I
was 18 I think so it's not that I want
us to go to war with Iran I want a
president and an Administration that is
so decisive and so well planned that
before our own dead make it home we've
settled the score and deterred them from
doing it again or you know and this is a
lot to ask for so decisive and so
strategic that we never have folks die
because there were never 170 attacks
that happened to begin with can I ask
you then what you think about the
decision or you know on the on the
timing of telegraphing that there was
going to be a response for several days
and that the irgc pulled all of its
leadership out of Syria yesterday I
think that President Biden truly
believes and this is not a hit against
him I truly believe believe the
President Biden's Administration their
strategy from the beginning and they're
sticking to it is they can buy and T
their way out of a potential crisis or
war and to date those things have only
made me feel less secure and made those
friends of mine serving in the military
feel less supported so I believe that
that is a part of their strategy we're
going to show a force but we're not
going to hurt you so bad that you feel
the need to retaliate I don't know that
President Trump ever had those concerns
and I felt much better about it back
then hey Joey you're in Georgia I spend
my weeks in Texas we come from a similar
background you of course have made great
sacrifice for this country on the
battlefield I'm curious when you bring
in your personal experience Joey and
everyone that you know Brett brought up
the polling shows America has no
appetite for another War you hear um
individuals like the general suggesting
that strikes are warranted in Iran Wars
don't happen overnight T night they kind
of metastasize from a bunch of small
decisions you end up in a war you know
we don't launch Wars anymore we don't de
we certainly don't declare Wars anymore
we remember when the last time we had a
congressional declaration of war do you
think there's a case for any leader
right now to be made that convinces the
American public that we should be
messing around with war with
Iran you know my my biggest concern is
that I was a part of a 20-year war that
ended so desperately that the American
people I don't know if they don't have
an appetite for war as much as they
don't trust their government to take
them into a war no matter how just it
may appear or how necessary the cause
may be that's what's scary when the
American people who ultimately have to
spend the money and shed the blood no
longer trust their government to send
their sons and dolls or themselves to
war it's not about we don't we don't
have an appetite for war if something
like 911 happened today we would have
all the appetite in the world to go seek
retribution and prevent it from
happening but our faith in the system we
have and really that is broken down at
every level all along the way from the
taxes we pay to the borders we have to
the words we use and that is the
industry of politics making its way into
the minds and hearts of us to the point
that we don't trust our government for
our security anymore and that's the
biggest concern I have because that
leads to recruiting uh woes that leads
to defense spending Wows that leads to
the lindsy grams and con cotton calling
for what may be the best strategy but
every one of us sitting here going
that's a Warhawk that's someone that
just wants to drop bombs because that's
what we've seen for 20 years that's what
they've shown us for 20 years I lost my
legs in a war that Lindsey Graham would
say and I'm not beating up on him he's
just he's the most honest and vocal
advocate for his position but he would
say I lost my legs because he told me
this setting on the couch on Fox and
Friends and and my doll kind of drops
that I lost my leg because we we did the
right thing by fighting the war over
there and it didn't come here but you
know what that's an easy thing thing to
say when you get show me the
intelligence briefs when you can't do a
60 Minutes piece or or a Brett Bear
piece that shows those connections by
fact that we're told to just believe
that that we're told to just believe the
person who gets to be the press
secretary at that moment or gets to be
the president at that moment and I think
the American Appetite for believing the
facts as the government tells you has
gone out the window with the age of
information and some of the bigger
voices in politics right now uh
political commentary wonderfully said
Greg do you have anything from Joey no
it's always good to hear him cuz uh
literally he's the expert Y in my mind
and I just think I mean I just re
punishment I and Joey you can tell me to
shut up but I I punishment for me is
always you put somebody in a hole that
they wouldn't be in if they haven't
committed the infraction these things
always seem to me as incredibly
performative not as a deterrent but just
to say we did something because the the
bad guys end up back at the the starting
block where they just start back up you
know here's the deal Greg we spent 20
years taking out strategic Target after
strategic Target strategic person after
strategic person asset after asset of
our enemies and they never lost the
ability to harm us at about the same
rate yeah so it's hard for me to believe
that these bombings today reduce the
ability for our enemies in the region to
attack us and that's what's concerning
because if you're not sending the right
signal which I don't believe this is a
signal sending to anyone but the
American people at least do something
effective that stops their ability to
harm us and I don't I don't I don't have
the experience that would lead me to
believe that's what's happened today
Joey Jones thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else